I don't know whether to call this
projection distraction disinformation
what about ISM ad hominem straw Manning
or just through pity and maybe sometimes
the simplest explanation is actually the
best one in the middle of an
investigation
looking into possible illegal
coordination with Russia during the 2016
campaign that investigation as a
reminder has already brought close to 20
indictments five guilty pleas and
potentially many many more Donald Trump
is now accusing American ally Germany
and Chancellor Angela Merkel of being
Russian puppets and captives of the
Russians so some backstory is sort of
required to understand this but even the
backstory doesn't change that this is
about as dumb as it sounds at face value
we've got the NATO summit going on in
Brussels Belgium yesterday
beautiful city of Brussels one of my
favorites if you're ever there have the
seafood at Nords 'i have the ramen at
umami doh trust me on that folks believe
me beautiful city of Brussels Belgium
NATO summit Trump goes on a seemingly
unprovoked anti German tirade and why
not right he's alienated Canada he's
alienated France he's alienated the
United Kingdom Germany is kind of the
logical next country that you would go
out of your way to alienate and Trump
shows up completely out of control and
accuses Germany of being quote a captive
of the Russians effectively Russian
puppets why did he say this because of
an energy deal and I'm gonna let him
explain we're gonna play the video if
you're watching check out former senator
and current US representative to NATO
kay bailey hutchison the look on her
face says a lot here check out Mike
Pompeo on trump's left looking
physically in pain as Donald Trump makes
this horrible horrible diplomatic faux
pas and then look at chief of staff John
Kelly to Trump's far right on the other
side of kay Bailey Hutchinson over here
he just straight up looks away at one
point and then another point starts
chugging water nobody knowing how to
react to this just very bizarre unhinged
tirade from Trump take a listen to it
[Music]
it's very sad when Germany makes a
massive oil and gas deal with Russia
you're supposed to be guarding against
Russia and Germany goes out and pays
millions and billions of dollars a year
to Russia so we're protecting Germany
we're protecting France were protecting
all of these countries and then numerous
of the countries go out and make a
pipeline deal with Russia without paying
billions of dollars into the coffers of
Russia so we're supposed to protect you
against Russia but they're paying
billions of dollars to Russia and I
think that's very inappropriate and the
former Chancellor of Germany is the head
of the pipeline company that supplied
the gas ultimately Germany will have
almost 70 percent of their country
controlled by Russia with natural gas so
you tell me is that appropriate of any
way like been complaining about this all
the time I got it it should have never
been allowed to have happened but
Germany is totally controlled by Russia
because they were getting from 60 to 70%
of their energy from Russia and a new
pipeline rohan you tell me if that's
appropriate because I think it's not wow
just wow and then the actual diplomats
in the room try to sort of soften the
entire thing and Trump actually just
interrupts extraordinarily rudely with
even more complaints we have always been
able to unite around us to protect and
defend each other because we understand
that we are stronger together
oh I think the two world wars on the
Cold War focal stuff go stronger
together than apart but how do you be
together what any country is getting its
energy from the person you want
protection against or remedy that you
want to take because you understand that
when we stand together also in dealing
with Russia we are stronger I think what
we have seen is that you just make in
Russia richer well that the element make
it richer so I'm not doing this story to
try to convince trumpets that this is
really bad for the United States as
reputation around the world the trumpets
are gonna see this and they're gonna
think this is great is this Trump being
tough
this is Trump not backing down this is
embarrassing around the world the entire
world is laughing at us because we have
effectively a child here who doesn't
even know what the hell he's talking
about
it's first of all just not true that it
was as a result of this energy deal
Russia is going to get or Germany rather
is going to get 60 or 70 percent of its
energy from Russia like it just flat-out
untrue number two Trump hired as his
secretary of state a guy whose entire
claim to fame his entire career Rex
Tillerson as CEO of Exxon Mobil was the
the the making of deals with countries
like Russia for energy right and now all
of a sudden energy deals with Russia are
the problem and are indicative of being
a captive of Russia and then lastly the
right-wingers are off the rails on this
one and as soon as reasonable people on
the left and right say hey you know that
this is bad this is untrue it's bad
diplomacy there's people on the right
who are saying wait a second now you
like Russia and you're in favor of
Germany doing deals with Russia but when
Trump simply says it might be good to
have a better relationship with Russia
he's colluding no no no a deal with
Russia for energy and a pipeline and by
the way we're talking about Russian
companies not yet not even the
government necessarily that's not
collusion or obstruction of justice or
doing Russia's bidding you could be
against the deal right you could say it
would be better not to do these deals
with Russia and Russian companies you
could point out this is you know we're
against fossil fuels we should be moving
against fossil fuels you can be against
the specifics of the deal but you still
recognize that this is not what Trump is
accused of having done and is being
investigated for it's all projection
isn't it because Trump is the one with
countless ties to Russia yes it reminds
me of one of the debates between him and
Hillary Clinton where he said no puppet
no puppet you're the puppet that's
exactly what he's doing
I think projec I at the beginning I said
is this projection stupidity whatever I
think it is stupidity and ignorance but
it is also on some level projection
which is Trump panicking and trying to
just blame anybody he can of what he now
maybe is recognizing he may be guilty of
himself and this has the the may be
inadvertent impact of being really good
for Angela Merkel Merkel is in a really
tough electoral situation in Germany and
Trump by doing this positions her to
respond which she did saying she
remembers the Soviet occupation she's
the last one who should be lectured
about doing business with Russia this is
good for Merkel within Germany I don't
know that Trump recognizes or
necessarily even cares about that and as
far as Trump's behavior we owe an
apology to the rest of the world and the
right and Trump they don't want
apologies
they say weaklings apologize and strong
leaders don't stop doing things that
require apologies if you don't want
people demanding apologies anymore yeah
these are our allies and you can call
them out for sure but do so behind
closed doors not out in public it's just
embarrassing
I was thinking even behind closed doors
you wouldn't necessarily see this level
of direct disrespect and sort of
callousness towards allies and Crump is
doing this in front of cameras today's
program is sponsored in part by for tor
which is a social forecasting game for
your phone or web browsers that allows
players to come together and compete
with each other to predict future events
butour is built on the principles of
what's called a prediction market which
is a scientifically validated way of
leveraging the wisdom of the crowd to
better estimate the likelihood of future
events and there are a ton of different
topics including politics and here's how
it works you go on the app find a future
event that you feel confident enough
about to make a prediction and make a
bet on the outcome you think is most
likely to happen
using the apps in-game fake currency
your prediction is right you're rewarded
with more points and you compete with
others who are making their own
predictions to see who's the best
forecaster there's no real money or
cryptocurrency involved and that's kind
of the fun of it the whole point is use
this social network to prove how good
you are
at predicting the future I have an
account on the futur app and I make
predictions and you can place your bets
based on my predictions as well go to
futur comm to sign up and start making
forecasts it's totally free and it's
available on both Android and iOS and on
web browsers and right now on futur you
can win cash prizes for correct
predictions about the World Cup check it
out at fut you you are calm